[Music]
foreign
It's a Small World After All Because
today we're shrinking Earth to the size
of Pluto
but if our planet was this tiny how
would it alter the atmosphere
why would Earth get hotter
and how would gravity affect our water
supply
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Earth was the size of Pluto
Pluto sits on the Solar System's Edge
just beyond Neptune's orbit it was once
considered a planet but then in 2006
scientists demoted this Celestial body
to a dwarf planet all because Pluto
isn't big enough to gravitationally
dominate in its own orbit
after all this dwarf planet is only
two-thirds the diameter of our moon
so if Earth was as Tiny as Pluto how
would 8 billion people fit on it
say goodbye to your personal Elbow Room
we would have to fit everyone into an
area slightly bigger than Russia
71 percent of which would be covered
with oceans
but the good news is this shrunken Earth
would still have room for everyone
just barely
you and every person on the planet would
have about one and a half tennis courts
to yourselves
the problem is that doesn't take into
account the space we need for hospitals
airports and roads once we build those
things would start getting cramped
add to that all the uninhabitable areas
like deserts and mountains and you won't
have enough room to comfortably fit
everyone
but if you're looking for a quick Escape
it would be easy for you to make a break
for it
one jump could catapult you almost 7.6
meters into the air
and that leap would last for almost 10
seconds giving you a spectacular view of
the horizon
you could also run faster since there
would be less friction
but watch out for slick surfaces they
could send you flying long distances
because there wouldn't be enough gravity
to keep you in place
and refrain from over exerting yourself
with all this running
on this dwarf planet the air pressure
would also be small
so no matter where you're at it would
feel like standing on a Mountaintop 5
000 meters high
yeah with less oxygen to breathe you
would be constantly gasping for air
if you're lucky this high altitude
sickness will leave you lightheaded but
if you're unlucky it could kill you
but even that wouldn't be the worst case
scenario if the Milky Way always had a
mini Earth
technically the lack of gravity would
make earth uninhabitable a study out of
Harvard from 2019 found that a planet
needs a mass of at least 2.7 percent of
the earth to keep water on the surface
if Earth had formed to be the size of
Pluto four and a half billion years ago
it would never have its Mighty oceans
now how would this affect the Moon
well Pluto's largest moon Caron doesn't
orbit the dwarf planet instead the two
bodies are tidally locked with the same
sides always facing each other our dwarf
Earth would be forever facing the moon
in the same position locked in place by
a Common Center of mass caused by our
competing gravitational pulls
but all of this would be the least of
our problems
Earth was this small its inner core
would be much cooler
that might sound good at first
earthquakes would stop because there
wouldn't be shifting tectonic plates
anymore
volcanoes would become harmless
mountains
but unfortunately Earth wouldn't have a
protective magnetic field without the
hot molten core
with this gun the radiation from the Sun
would fry our planet
now what if Earth wasn't formed to be
the size of Pluto What If instead it
suddenly shrunk
well then our planet would keep its mass
but that would make the surface gravity
30 times stronger than what it is now
with intense training the human body can
survive on a planet with four times the
Earth's gravity but a planet with 10
times the gravity of Earth that would
break your bones
if you weighed 75 kilograms before
now you would weigh around
2300 kilograms every move you make would
take Serious muscle power and you may
not have it in you no matter how hard
you try
and instantaneous dwarf Earth would
cause Mass devastation
it could destroy everything we love
about this planet and leave Humanity
hanging on for dear life
now maybe we would have a better chance
if the planet was larger
what if Earth was the size of Jupiter
well keep watching because that's a
story for another
but
if
[Music]